many schools across venezuela have
reopened their classrooms 19 months
after the pandemic forced them to close
and after several delays due to rising
rates of infection
we've created the conditions to return
safely to classrooms the administrations
and the teachers have been working to
make sure the return is safe so that
parents feel comfortable
after so long without face-to-face
learning or playing with his friends
juan is clear about what he expects from
school
he says he wants two things to play and
to learn
his mother miriam says she was nervous
about the return but it was necessary
is happy to be coming back they needed
communication with other kids to play to
share things with their teachers that
motivation
the government has called the reopening
campaign a drop of love for my school
this video released on one of president
nicolas maduro's social media accounts
shows workers sprucing up school
buildings and the state delivering vital
learning equipment although he admits
many pupils have abandoned their
education
[Music]
we'll invite them back so they can
return to the classroom
however many teachers and parents say
buildings are in disrepair supplies are
low and thousands of teachers the lowest
paid in the region have left the
profession or join the millions who have
fled venezuela to escape poverty and
inflation
i don't think the conditions are
suitable for children to return there
are schools that lack water that are not
equipped that don't have the
infrastructure
many teachers like johanna have
supplemented their meager incomes by
inviting pupils into their homes
we are very concerned because we are
going to find many gaps in their
education for example if they were in
first grade when the pandemic began
they have already passed the second or
third and maybe they don't know how to
read
official figures say the virus has
killed less than 5 000 people in
venezuela and infected four hundred
thousand however many health experts
dispute those numbers as well as the
government claim that it has vaccinated
eighty percent of teachers
the welcome return to school in
venezuela is proving to be fraught with
difficulties with the kovit 19 pandemic
highlighting and exacerbating many of
the problems the country's education
system was already facing
[Music]
al jazeera